et un truc est étrange retour sur terre
après une spéciale c'est que c'est comme
s'ils allaient si moi je passais en
orbite c'était un rêve
pourtant ce qu'a vécu david
saint-jacques est bien réelle
il y a quatre jours à peine l'astronaute
de 49 ans était encore dans l'espace
depuis houston au texas
il a raconté en détail la fin de son
odyssée son retour sur la terre ferme
c'est là que l'on devient une étoile
filante et lançant contre wav qu'on veut
on se déplace après à 8 kilomètres par
seconde ces c'est la vitesse hôpital on
rentre dans l'atmosphère un et pas que
la politique du silence
bush en la place nette en voient l'herbe
des steppes kazakhes qui brasse 1
hu on est revenu sur terre le retour à
la gravité et brutale comme c'est le cas
pour tous les astronautes david saint
jacques qui est apparu affaibli
incapable de tenir en équilibre mais
grand garçon me compare alors tu sors il
aura besoin de plusieurs semaines même
deux mois pour être complètement rétabli
de son séjour en orbite mais déjà les
nausées sont choses du passé et david
saint jacques se porte bien
ça va mieux il faut dire que les six
derniers mois ont été bien rempli cette
mission spatiale la plus longue pour un
astronaute canadien a été ponctuée de
grande première vraiment les astronautes
ont été tout à fait à la hauteur ils ont
accompli beaucoup plus de choses même
que ce qu'on aurait crus capables
à commencer par une sortie de plus de
six heures dans l'espace puis par
l'attraper cosmique d'un vaisseau dragon
à l'aide du bras canadien
le travail est loin d'être terminé pour
david saint jacques
il terminera à des expériences
scientifiques amorcé en orbite et devra
subir plusieurs examens médicaux
en plus d'être soumis à un régime
alimentaire unique forcément régime
alimentaire très strict c'est 100% leur
seraient préparées par moi et mon épouse
[Rires]
tous mes enfants seront du très bon
affaires des anglais
s'il apprécie ce retour avec les siens
la camaraderie à bord de la station
spatiale internationale et ce sentiment
de faire oeuvre utile lui manqueront
presque autant que le paysage la vue de
la planète qui est vraiment
époustouflante ça à chaque fois je me
fais mes yeux encore que je
j'imagine cette ville de hull
puissamment armés mais ici qui me
permette radio canada montréal